the Netflix roster of Marvel shows has
already shown that they're capable of
drawing some great moments from the
comics and transferring them to the
screen and with the Punisher they're
spoiled for choice with hundreds of
comics and decades of stories to draw
from all built around hard-hitting ultra
violent action there are plenty of
brutal moments that are begging to be
recreated there is however a problem
unique to the Punisher a lot of his
stories might just be too intense to
work on the show and the more are just
intensely weird and yes they're actually
weirder than this
here are some Punisher comic book
moments that will never make it to
Netflix army of one it goes without
saying that any media project involving
Frank Castle is going to draw heavily
from garthe and is's eight years of
writing the character the Netflix shows
have already started with an adaptation
of the issue with a Punisher ties
daredevil up to witness a rooftop
execution but over the course of those
eight years and it's got into some
pretty extreme stories in army of one
The Punisher took on an entire island
full of killer mercenaries including his
longtime nemesis the Russian who we've
seen in the 2004 Punisher movie
[Music]
so why is the story so problematic
well it's French solution that causes
trouble going for the nuclear option
literally the story ends with a mushroom
cloud when the Punisher drops an atomic
bomb onto the island and it's mercenary
inhabitants wiping them all from the
face of the earth cracked down
considering that the shows have already
introduced Luke Cage it's easy to
imagine that they might want to tie the
Punisher into the MCU
by recreating one of their classic team
ups unfortunately the most notable
meeting involves Frank Castle changing
his skin colour and pretending to be a
black man for three issues until he
eventually fades back to his usual
Caucasian complexion in cracktown
Frank is sent to jail and gets his face
carved up by the bad guy jigsaw after
that we see Frank's face get repaired by
a surgeon whose experimental technique
involved pumping the Punisher full of
the skin pigment melanin the result was
a dark skinned and ridiculously
inappropriate Punisher who teamed up
with Luke Cage in Chicago to bring down
a ring of crack dealers and an army of
ninjas needless to say after three
issues this whole thing was never
mentioned again Franken Castle believe
it or not the tail of the temporarily
black Frank Castle isn't actually the
weirdest Punisher story and neither is
the time he became an angel who killed
demons with magical ghost guns no that
honor goes to when he spent a year as a
Frankenstein in 2009 the notorious
supervillain Norman Osborn better known
to spider-man fans as a Green Goblin was
put in charge of national security an
unrepentant murderer in a position of
power made for a tempting target and
Frank set his sights on taking Osborn
down the problem Frank's just a guy with
a lot of guns and Osborn had his own
team of Dark Avengers protecting him
darken the son of Wolverine ended up
chopping the punisher to pieces and
throwing his body into a sewer where it
was found and stitched back together by
Morbius the living vampire who
resurrected him to protect a secret city
of monsters underneath Manhattan chances
are good that won't happen on TV anytime
soon even if Jon Bernthal with the
pretty greatest of Frankenstein Punisher
kills Nick Fury if they've really wanted
to tie Bernthal version of The Punisher
to the larger Marvel Cinematic Universe
they could always go with one of
banks are the big encounters with the MC
used most prominent characters like that
time he murdered Nick Fiore in 1995 the
Punisher was captured by renegade shield
agents and brainwashed into believing
that it was actually Fury who killed his
family so he shot and killed them after
a manhunt involving the Avengers he was
arrested and sentenced to death in the
electric chair because it's comics
neither death really lasted long it was
later revealed that Tony Stark had
invented a special life model decoy
robot that managed to fool everyone and
the Punisher he was rescued from the
electric chair by a mafioso who wanted
him to take over his organization he
actually agreed and briefly joined up as
a new head of an organized crime family
Frank's hydrophobia in the pages of
Punisher War Journal we finally
discovered the Punishers weakness a
crippling fear of open water dating back
to a childhood trauma because what the
Punisher really needed was to have a
more traumatic past when Frank found
himself tracking down a gang of drug
dealers to Hawaii his fear almost got
him killed
luckily he was rescued from drowning by
a friendly dolphin and then conquered
his sphere with the help of a local
Kahuna who healed his spirit with magic
at the request of a ninja master no
really even if it's unlikely we'll ever
see this story make it to the screen
let's not kid ourselves it would be
amazing who wouldn't want to see Frank
Castle wearing a bright Hawaiian shirt
over his Punisher outfit or watch The
Punisher ride a jet ski the cover blurb
says it all you just rented a jet ski to
the Punisher kiss that baby goodbye
Punisher meets Archie if there's a Hall
of Fame for bizarre comic book
crossovers then the Punisher meets
Archie it's a first-round pick
originally published in 1994 it stands
as one of the weirdest of all time even
after a decade of Archie meeting
everyone from Barack Obama and Sarah
Palin for the predator to sharknado yes
that sharknado
but incredibly this team-up is actually
more plausible than ever on TVs
Riverdale a show of no shortage of
murders the Archie gangs come through a
pretty dark reimagining so having Frank
Castle rolled up to lay down some
vigilante justice wouldn't seem strange
at all is it going to happen
no but if we don't at least get a cameo
appearance from Archie actor KJ Harper
as a redheaded criminal on the run from
the Punisher then what are we even doing
here thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]